in the Brazilian Court of bail-ins
bustling marketplace a woman is arming
herself for battle against dark forces
in the same market another medium has
more sinister intentions both are
practitioners of a religion called goon
banda here in northeastern Brazil in
banda mixes freely with catholicism
brought to the region by african slaves
it's a religion founded on spirits both
good and evil since you lady was a
teenager she has been possessed by
spirits spirits that she says can lift
curses and foretell the future there's a
pathetic her main spirit guide maria
conga works only for good TV foolish
people come here all the time and ask me
to kill someone what do the poor I tell
them and they have knocked on the wrong
door mother the way I just quietly here
we don't agree but they brought the
harder
Paquito receives clients in a small shop
behind his house
today poquito slient is a woman who
claims she's in an abusive marriage she
requests a rather extreme solution and
we want you to do the work to kill my
husband for poquito it's not an
unreasonable request he sees conjuring
evil as a service to people spirit media
Maria's new lady also has a client Joana
believes that an evil spirit has placed
a curse on her she has numerous medical
problems that doctors have been unable
to cure to negotiate with the evil
spirit haunting Johanna the lady must
find out which one is the culprit to do
that she will enter the realm of spirits
offering her own body as a vessel on
this night the lady is visited by many
spirits but it is the one called bayano
grande who solves the riddle of Joanna's
curse Rouge Lady Diana orders Joanna and
her son Claudio to go outside with him
he admits he is to blame for the curse
you have to ask for mercy if you don't I
will never look this curse from you
[Music]
what have I done to my ex-girlfriend to
deserve this you have done nothing but
your mother has because she fought with
him she quarreled bayano listens to
their pleas and decides to grant their
wish he lifts the curse it has been a
long and successful evening or so they
believe
two weeks have passed since Paquito put
a deadly curse on the husband of his
client he claims the curse has done its
job but it what happened to miss Ramirez
husband he died can you show us where
the bravest no no I will not show you
his grave meanwhile zoo lady had planned
to cleanse Joanna's house of any
residual evil but she never gets the
chance
joanna has died gossip is spreading that
Joanna died because you lady failed to
get rid of the curse though badly shaken
by the death the lady has resolved to
carry on with her work in the Yoon Banda
religion evil is both a force to fight
and of course to enlist on your behalf
the spirits are at your service